[Music]
my life
hasn't been what you probably think it
has
we all have our struggles have you ever
been in love a long long time ago
you so many times yeah all the time
[Music]
welcome to the future life is good but
it can be better
why shouldn't it be all you need
is to want
think about finally having everything
you always
wanted i can save today
but you can save the world
steve
now i take what i want in return
everyone will see
[Music]
i will need you
you know you need to do
[Music]
nothing good is born from lies
and greatness is not what you think
[Music]
it's all art
the that's just a trash can it's just a
trash can yeah yeah
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
[Music]
his exploits
legendary
what he has to teach you may very well
mean the difference between life
and death
your reputation precedes you have to
admit i wasn't expecting an invitation
back
they're called orders maverick
[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking today's exercise
is dog fighting two versus what he's
gotta be kidding
[Music]
smoke in the air
i used to have nothing
and then i got this job
[Music]
this family
but nothing lasts forever
i heard you had to leave in a hurry it's
never easy these days
so what are you going to do i've lived a
lot of lives
but i'm done running from my past
i know you're out there i know you know
i'm out here
so we're gonna talk like grown-ups
is that what we are
it's good to see you too sis
what brings you home
we have unfinished business
we have to go back to where it all
started
lucky us one thing's for sure
it's gonna be a hell of a
[Music]
still reunion family
back together again you got fat
[Music]
[Music]
why would i betray you we all have our
secrets
we just didn't get to yours yet
the world is arming faster than we can
respond
where's double oh seven
i need a favor brother you're the only
one i trust for this
the world's moved on commander bond you
were double o
two yes
i thought you two would get along
james bond so you're not dead hello pew
i've missed you
it's the most valuable asset this
country has if you feel yourself losing
control i'm not going to lose
patrol
james you gave up everything for her
when our secret finds its way out it'll
be the death of him
what is it you don't know what this is
james bond license to kill
his story of violence
i could be speaking to my own reflection
only your skills die with your body
mine will survive long after i'm gone
history isn't kind to men who play god
[Music]
we all believe we've run into the
burning building
but until we feel that heat
we can never know
you do
[Music]
you chose to die instead of giving up
your colleagues
that test you passed
not everybody does
welcome to the afterlife
do what i do i need some idea of the
threat we face
as i understand it we're trying to
prevent world war iii
nuclear holocaust no
something worse
all i have for you is a word tell it
it'll open the right doors
some of the wrong ones too
you have to start looking at the world
in a new way
don't try to understand it
[Music]
feel it
it'll happen here hasn't happened yet
oh
[Applause]
and fast cars don't make you batman mike
[Applause]
get me the [ __ ] out of this car
mike we got more time behind us than in
front please i'ma be running down
criminals until i'm 100.
not me i'm returned
what happened to bad boys for life it's
time we be good man
who the [ __ ] wants to sing that song
mike i'll put you on a new team you're
working with ammo now
yeah ammo is a high school musical boy
band with guns
you look great grandpa so you're that
guy there's always one right up till
there's not
that's what i like teamwork
[Music]
marcus somebody's trying to kill me who
wants to kill you
i don't trust a person that don't want
to kill him he'll put my name up there
thanks a lot we got it marcus we
appreciate it
but family is the only thing that
matters so i'm not letting you go on the
suicide mission alone
one last time one last time
oh [ __ ] get in here
[Music]
helicopters
oh this is my wife's car give me the
front door
she knows she always knows
[Applause]
do you know why the phoenix sits on the
right hand of the emperor
she is his guardian
his her that she's both beautiful
and strong your job
is to bring honor to the family
do you think you can do that
citizens we are under attack from
northern
invaders their leader calls himself
oricon
fights alongside a witch they'll survive
us
by edict of his imperial majesty every
family must contribute
one man to fight have you no son
i am blessed with two daughters i will
fight
we must be strong
this time he will not return
loyal brave
and true it is my duty to protect my
family
[Music]
ancestors please protect her
what is your name soldier partying
commander son of pojo
we're gonna make men out of every single
one of you the spirit
is evident that something holds you back
[Music]
when they find out who you are they will
show you
no mercy
[Music]
i'm hua mulan i will bring honor to us
[Music]
all
and initiate sequences
what is this what i'm sorry to be the
one to tell you this but you
got yourself killed at rst
we'd rebuild the most important assets
in the u.s military
soldiers like yourself you're the first
who we've successfully managed to bring
back but improved enhanced
with the technology in your veins you
have an army inside you
that will not only make you stronger he
will heal you instantly
now tell me do you remember anything
where are you going i got unfinished
business
i'm gonna find the man who murdered my
wife and killed him
[Music]
oh that's not good all right set him
down
and initiate sequence
[Music]
okay who is the next target for
elimination
tell me do you remember anything do i
know you guys
i don't think so
i've been manipulating you
what you think is real sometimes i ain't
and initiate sequence
revenge is what makes a man like you
exceptional you know nothing about men
like me
that is absolutely fantastic
i feel like i just heard this are they
putting this in repeat
this will not be a war of heroes
which is all to see this is going to be
fun
the world burns you have no idea of what
men are capable of
we must do something i know you want to
fight
but there are other ways of doing our
duty
you're going to need a suit come
on we are the first independent
intelligence agency preserving peace
and protecting life welcome to the
in their club
just like witches at black masses
while governments wait for orders our
people
take action evil
mindset destruction now it's time to
show the world
sorcerer of death construction
how mighty you were
[Music]
our enemies think we are gentlemen
but reputation is what people think of
you
character is what you are
armed and ready
but ready we shall see
this is called a parachute
it means that one can jump out of a
plane safely
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
mondays am i right joe you said it guy
yeah
[Music]
don't have a good day have a great day
everybody down on the ground
hey bud you ever think that there's got
to be more
more than what stuff we do day after day
being shot at run over
take it hostage everybody's down on the
ground
today's gonna be different hi
god this isn't you you don't do this man
maybe i do
dude this is scary
he's just resting in pieces that man
is dead he's so sleepy
[Music]
wow
[Music]
is this what recreational drugs feel
like
[Music]
guy this world it's a video game
and it's full of bad guys i'm a rule
breaker
i'm a rattle chicka chicka snaker
we need you to be the good guy
i'm sorry
wow giddy up is that a glock in your
pocket
no what it's two blocks
oh
[Music]
i'm not gonna be the good guy i'm gonna
be the great guy
okay well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity
you know what a harlequin is a
harlequin's role
is to serve it's nothing without a
master
no one gives two shits who we are
beyond that
the joker and i broke up
i wanted a fresh start but it turns out
i wasn't the only demon gotham looking
for emancipation
spectacular news
miss queen she blocks me
who are you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
you need me
he's after all of us now none of us
are walking out of here
we should order pizza make cosmos
who's having a good time get ready
ladies
oh you're that psycho chick you never
call a woman chick i'll accept
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway honestly
my mom won't say it but we're completely
broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate that has no fault lines
no fracking
no loud music even is shaking on a daily
basis
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room killer
replica
a replica of what a ghost trap
hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30 years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom my grandfather died
my mom says we're just here to pick
through the roblox life
wait a minute
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it fate
[Music]
call it lock
call it karma
[Music]
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a gunner seat
[Music]
[Music]
legend has it there is a tree in the
amazon that possesses unparalleled
healing powers
and the arrowhead is the key to
unlocking it
hello uh just wanted you to know this
has been mislabeled
he's shipping outlets
of all the jungle cruises you can take
in the amazon this one is undoubtedly
the cheapest but also the most thrilling
heads up coming through
look out
marauders
natives
ladies and gentlemen the moment you've
all been waiting for
the backside of water
steve's wonder of the world
we're headed up river to la grimas de
cristal when we secure our travel come
on
hello not a good time my brother and i
are looking for passage upriver please
go away
i have a lot of money
if you believe in legends you should
believe in curses too
you're gonna beg me to turn back well i
look forward to disappointing you
ten thousand to bring you there alive
dead it's 15 000.
why should i pay more dead
dead i'd have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady
here we go
oh god sorry frank sorry strong form
i cannot win you booked the river cruise
and you can't swim
the price just went up
is real
listen carefully you are now 5 000 miles
from land
and you're descending seven miles to the
bottom of the ocean
see you all in a month here we go
[Music]
all right we're gonna do this let's do
this
[Music]
let's kill from one to ten how bad's my
rig
i drilled to the bottom of the ocean and
we don't know what came out
gotta get to the station how will you
even get there
we walk we're just gonna walk with
insufficient oxygen across the bottom of
the ocean
you don't know what's out there worst
idea ever
what was that it's really tough
there's something following us
i want you to play a game with me ray i
don't want to play a game oh please
no i said play a game with me raymond
right lovely i want you to imagine
a character your boss mickey pearson
you're too smart to be blackmailing us
fletcher
sweet mary jane is my advice your poison
on the other hand is and always has been
the destroyer of
worlds you're out of touch and i would
like you to consider an offer
i am not for sale
the plot begins to thicken
now i can't be specific about the heroes
and zeros
but our protagonist is a hungry animal
there is a lot of money hanging in the
balance our antagonist explodes on the
scene like a millennial firework
and has indirectly started a war i think
you need to see this boss
what's the one of my final rocks
how do they find it i'm making inquiries
his name is fox we're spelled with a pa
so i was going for hawk
please sorry for hold kind of a hawk
if you smell smoke it's because there's
a fire
so you're gonna have to stamp that out
quickly
these people are gonna clean house and
you are part of that house
in the jungle the only way a lion
survived
not by acting like a game
[Music]
oh it's really warming up now isn't it
there's only one rule in this jungle
when the lion's hungry
he eats
[Music]
one of her associates on an accident
say you killed someone no it was the
gravity that killed him
[Music]
gonna need those phones
um it's
an instinct
feeling the force brought us together
we're not alone
good people will fight if we lead them
people keep telling me they know me
[Music]
no one does
[Music]
[Applause]
but i do
how long have i waited
[Applause]
and now
[Applause]
you're coming together
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
3po taking one last look sir
at my friends
confronting fear is the destiny of a
jedi
[Music]
your destiny
[Applause]
[Music]
the force will be with you always
there's this trick that we all do to get
through our day
we take a box and into that box we place
all
the [ __ ] of the world
and we close the box and pretend it
doesn't exist
only some of us we've lost our ability
to pretend
we've been looking for a special
operator like you for a while
who are you
[Music]
which is dirty work others can't
here's the fun part from now on you're
dead
it's all erased no more criminal records
no more getting arrested just for
being naked or just usual stuff you know
being naked getting drunk
casual stuff so we're all going to die
we blend in
to disappear watch me
is this going to work i hope so
this might we need to move honestly i
didn't think we'd make it this far
what's the status
hello this is so stressful
rojo hi hey hey
we're all gonna die may as well do it
while we're alive
sounds fun right
[Music]
[Applause]
where's the jungle this is a whole new
thing nobody told us we had to do a
whole new video
okay something went wrong
[Music]
come on i'm coming grandpa eddie good
morning
did you guys see spencer miss that
i think he went back in we gotta go get
him you know something
we haven't even picked our guys yet
are we in florida oh my god wait
we're in the wrong body my joints feel
like butter
oh no loose myself
this can't be happening i came back and
things actually got worse look at this
dude we have some issues here the game
is busted listen up now
this is a dangerous place you got to
have eyes in the back of your head
just happened to him the hell is this
would you look at me i haven't looked
like this since never
you look like this never i think my eyes
are a different color
all of you is a different color check
this out strengths and weaknesses
linguistics oh goodness nunchucks that's
new
damn that's a good list weaknesses heat
sun and sand how is this guy a character
in an adventure game
man it is hot out here we have to find
spencer and bethany
this next adventure is even more
challenging this time
not all of you will leave the game alive
best we thought you might need some help
where is bethany she's right here
she says oh my god like i'm a total
horse yep that's bethany
[Music]
hey
you are a terrible driver what are you
talking about
i just passed my driver's test last
month again
we're not gonna make it we're gonna make
it i don't think we're gonna make it
we're gonna make it
we're not gonna make it
[Music]
what happened yes i'm back i missed you
so much oh my god you guys hi
bethany you guys we're back in jumanji
[Music]
you